there's no sign from his legal team that
donald trump is preparing to concede
in fact they're digging in for a long
legal battle even though almost all
their court actions until now have been
dismissed
now claiming without producing any
evidence there's been a democratic
and international conspiracy to steal
the presidential election
this is real it is not made up it is not
there's nobody here
that engages in fantasies i've tried 100
cases
i prosecuted some of the most dangerous
criminals in the world
i know crimes i can smell them you don't
have to smell this one
i can prove it to you 18 different ways
donald trump's own election security
agency declared the 2020 presidential
election the most secure in american
history
the president has both taken credit for
that and declared the democrats
stole the election he also fired the
head of the agency
one of his lawyers baselessly claims
there's been
communist interference in the election
what we are really dealing with here and
uncovering more by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money through venezuela
cuba and likely china in the
interference
with our elections here in the united
states the trump campaign says it
intends to file a number of lawsuits in
a number of states in the coming days
yet in the lawsuits filed so far it has
stopped short of claiming
widespread voter fraud and it's produced
no evidence of the conspiracy claims
it's making now while the legal battles
go on the trump administration continues
to block transition planning
president-elect joe biden's frustration
is growing
and said donald trump is sending a
terrible message about democracy
it's hard to fathom how this man thinks
it's hard to fathom
i i'm confident he knows he hasn't won
and is not going to be able to win and
we're going to be sworn into january
20th
and i just uh you know but
far for me to question his motive it's
just it's just outrageous what he's
doing
with no states reporting widespread
issues the trump campaign's efforts to
prove fraud seem doomed to fail
but it could delay final confirmation
and trump's acceptance
of what seems inevitable alan fisher al
jazeera at the white house